hello my name is liam gallaher i'd like
to thank the organizers for of via
conference live for giving me the
opportunity to speak to you today
i'm actually calling from um a very wet
ireland uh in dublin
uh so hopefully the weather in your
respective locations a bit better
so i'm going to talk today really about
the use of antibody based proteomics and
digital pathology to fast-track
molecular diagnostics particularly in
the oncology setting
and in terms of my affiliations i'm
having a academic appointment within
university college dublin
i also spun out a company called
anchormark which i'll briefly mention
towards the end which is focused on
molecular diagnostics
so if you look at
i suppose across different therapeutic
areas we have a problem in the area of
oncology in the sense that most of drugs
which are used in oncology are pretty
ineffective
and there's a big issue in terms of
variability of patient responses
so this problem really also represents
an opportunity within the area of
personalized medicine in the fact that
can we identify particular biomarkers
that can actually be used to stratify
patients for appropriate therapies
there's also another driving force
behind this in the sense that
it's predicted by 2020 that most
medicines will be paid on the basis of
results
so if we look at cancer we know that
it's a an enormous problem and it's
growing obviously with the aging
population
given that cancer is a age-related
disorder we're seeing a huge increase in
the incidence of cancer
now we've made a lot of progress in
terms of
treating certain types of cancer
but are still an issue in terms of
effective utilization of therapies
and again from
both
a medical but also a commercial
perspective this area of molecular
diagnostics particularly oncology is a
huge growth area
a good example of this is an area of
melanoma
so very recently in the last few years
we've identified
specific mutations for example within
the brac protein which are
drivers of
melanoma within approximately half
patients with melanoma
and again more recently inhibitors very
targeted inhibitors that have been
developed which specifically
work against these b rat mutated
melanomas
so if you look here this is from
other work
published by weigel at iowa you can see
a patient with pretty aggressive disease
before treatment
if you look at
following very early on into treatment
with these braf inhibitors you get a
very striking response now but the
problem is even though you get this
somewhat magical response in pretty much
all cases you get relapse over time and
again this is a continuous battle that
we're faced with in a cancer setting is
really to
continuously offset this resistance
phenotype
another issue to consider is that a lot
of the emerging therapies which are
being used in cancer setting are
extremely expensive so again if you look
at this treatment here this braf
specific mutant b rap specific treatment
we're talking about between 50 to
60 000 euros or dollars or equivalent
over treatment
cycle
now
personalized medicine we see as as
really as a goal uh
it's not really just rescuing drugs but
it's also a way that drugs potentially
should be developed uh there's a concept
that we we can actually co-develop
companion diagnostics along with the
actual standard drug development process
and again one of the drivers behind that
is the fda have a fast track drug
approval process where you have a drug
accompanied by a companion diagnostic
another driving force is really that the
pairs are not reimbursing
um
unless there's actually demonstrated
really a concrete effect in terms of
improvement in terms of survival
now i've been working this area of
cancer for about two decades and we
particularly focus on cancer biomarkers
particularly in the area of tissue-based
biomarkers when a cancer is presented
but cancer biomarkers can be used really
in a lot of different contexts within
the oncology setting so for example they
can be used for early stage for example
in risk assessment or early detection
but what we're particularly interested
in when the disease actually presents
with the
for example a solid tumor can we
actually look at particular
proteins or genes which are expressed
within that tissue specimen and actually
use that information to determine
outcome but also response importantly
response to treatment
now if you look at
say commercial assets particularly in
the breast cancer setting there are two
assets which i'm going to briefly talk
about which are pretty well known in the
field one is mammoprint which is a
commercial diagnostic produced by a
dutch company called agenda
and they published a key paper in nature
which i'll refer to later on uh just
over a decade ago in 2002
where they actually defined a set of 70
genes
that could actually be used to predict
um
outcome of early early-stage breast
cancer patients what's interesting about
this particular signature it was the
first fda-approved multi-index assay
approved of its type as approved back in
2007.
and again this is this particular assay
is done in a
focused dna microwave format
there is a an equivalent type of assay
which is not done in the microwave
format but it's on using rtbcr which is
commercialized by general mchell called
oncotype dx
this specific assay is a
21 gene signature there are 16
informative genes and five control genes
what's interesting about this assay is
that it's not fda approved it's actually
run in a under um a clear within a clear
proof setting it's essentially a
laboratory derived test
but there's a very a very significant
number of patients which actually have
been assessed using this technology
across the world
and again this particular assay is doing
something similar to the mammogram assay
is predicting chemotherapy benefit
within a particular subset of patients
which we're not really sure how to treat
early stage breast cancer patients we
know that
um in this subcourt of patients we're
generally over treating those patients
with chemotherapy approximately 70 to 80
of those patients don't require
chemotherapy whereas between twenty and
thirty percent of patients do require
chemotherapy and these assays both
mammoprint and ocdx are there really to
try to identify low risk and high-risk
patients in this context
from a kind of health economic
perspective these assays they range and
cost approximately they're around four
thousand dollars
three and a half four thousand dollars
uh per assay
and again there are lots of studies out
there really you know determining
whether this these particular assays
are really provide benefit from a health
economic viewpoint
what's interesting from from my own
national viewpoint from an irish
viewpoint was that initially this uh for
example
ex-assay was not
uh given approval for use in uh public
patients uh we have a public private uh
patient process within ireland
what was interesting that was that was
changed around very recently such that
all patients within ireland
can actually get access to
this particular technology
the first uh was the first country in
europe in this context
so again what i would like to do just
briefly do is kind of stand back a bit
now and just talk a bit more about
biology
so
these particular assays what we're
really trying to do is look at the
primary tumor look at the genes which
are expressed in the primary tumor to
actually predict an event that could
happen a number of years down the line
and so on the left hand side of this
image you can see a cartoon of the
metastatic process where you get for
example escape
of
cancer cells from
the primary tumor can enter into
circulation and for example if you go to
the secondary sites in terms of
metastases
on the right hand side in a
administrator we're just going to show
you a movie and in that movie you will
actually see fluorescently tagged human
tumor cells moving through the
bloodstream it's just one aspect of that
process so if you could just play that
movie now please
okay so we're back here so that was just
really a movie which is courtesy of bob
hoffman from anti-cancer incorporated
and the idea really it's just really one
aspect of the this metastatic cascade
so this is really a picture i use really
to represent that's what my view of of
cancer we really
and also my weekend within ireland
driving my kids around but really it's a
we have a pretty good picture of what's
going on in the biological setting
within cancer
but the actual detail is missing and
really and that's really what i'm going
to talk about over the next
few
minutes so we've uh over the last
decade or even longer we've carried out
a lot of discovery using various
different omnic profiling approaches
gene expression profiling proteomics etc
and really there's um this discovery
there's a huge uh uh discovery process
but the actual conversion of this new
knowledge into something that's actually
clinically useful is really falling
behind so there's really a key problem
in terms of
validation or translation of this
information into
something that's useful
so one thing that we've tried to do is
within a breast cancer setting is we've
actually brought together gene
expiration data from multiple different
published studies where we have from
particularly from dna microwave studies
where we have survival information from
those patients so we've just published
this paper just recently in breast
cancer research which is pretty widely
used it's a it's a freely accessible
tool particularly aimed at the average
biologist which perhaps wouldn't have a
huge amount of
a clinical biostatistical training or a
huge amount of bioinformatic
capabilities and the idea behind this is
that is a we've developed a
user-friendly interface to interrogate
genes or candidate genes that you think
may have some prognostic role within a
cancer setting or breast cancer setting
and so uh what our our bar foundation
who
carried out this work he actually
integrated data from 26 different data
sets
from 12 different microwave platforms
essentially over four and a half
thousand samples where we have clinical
data
and expression information
and again if you're interested you can
actually
look at this web link and you can
actually interrogate specific genes of
interest and it's going to give you some
examples of what you can actually get
from this type of
in silico based analyses
and so if you look at some genes for
example on this oncotype dx
panel some of the 16 genes
you can actually look at the
the prognostic utility of those genes
across that four and a half thousand
patient set
on an individual basis and so for
example you can look on the bot top left
you can see the value of ki 67 a pretty
well known prognostic marker in in
cancer and then some other probably more
novel markers stk 15 surviving an mmp
11.
and a key thing to emphasize is that
really there's a suppose that there's a
a key
tipping point where if you actually
combine
you can actually each of those markers
potentially holds value as a prognostic
marker in your own setting
but when you actually combine them
together if you actually combine too
many genes together you actually
potentially can lose prognostic value
and so this is this idea that
on one level you may not require all 16
genes from um informative genes from the
octet dxa so you can potentially reduce
that down to three or four genes of
interest and again it's how you really
combine these together as a signature
and again people you can look at other
genes using this resource
so we published a few papers on the
application of this piece of software uh
our database called breastmark
these are just two highlighted studies
one we published with um matthias mann
in cancer research just over a year ago
what matthias did is he actually carried
out a very comprehensive proteomic
profiling effort in breast cancer and he
came up with about 55 g proteins which
were differentially expressed during
progression in
breast cancer and then what we did is we
went back and actually looked at the
value of these at the orni level using
this wider clinical resource and showed
which of those hold held value
on the right hand side just referring to
paper we published in the first issue of
cancer discovery with lisa cousins group
and she was interested really in the
role of the inflammatory response in
breast cancer and how this could impact
on
a chemotherapy response and in this case
what we're doing is looking at
surrogates of immune cell
infiltration by looking at expression of
particular markers and shown there's
utility there
so what i'm going to shift really now is
really the main part of my talk which is
use of antibody based proteomics
and if you're interested in this area in
a bit more detail we published a review
article in nature reviews cancer over or
two years ago where we kind of reviewed
the different different aspects of
antibody based proteomics
i'm not really going to cover all of
those today so again as part of our
strategy we integrate data from multiple
different platforms it could be gene
expression data
proteomic data or functional screens
and then we use antibodies in a pretty
much high throughput manner to validate
these candidates on additional patient
samples and i'll talk about particularly
the technology that we use we use tissue
microwave technology to look at large
numbers of clinical specimens
what i'm not going to talk about today
is really the application of reverse
rate protein arrays or antibody arrays
but you can actually find other
resources for that
now a particular aspect of the use of
tissue microwaves which i'll introduce
in a minute is that we were really
driven towards the development of
automated image analysis tools to
actually uh facilitate the quantitation
of our data
so if you're not if you're not familiar
with what a tissue microarray is it's
really a platform for high throughput
and pathology where you can on the left
hand side you've got your conventional a
piece of tumor tissue that a a
surgeon obviously would remove and then
hand it over to a pathologist who would
fix and form and embed in paraffin and
put into a tissue block and then carry
out standard full face sectioning on and
so what you can do with a tissue
microwave is you can actually take small
cores of tissue from each of those
blocks put them into a master block and
then you can actually put hundreds of
clinical specimens on a single block
and this is very powerful because you
can actually create
obviously sections of that tissue
microarray and you can look at
expression of markers of interest but
importantly within a morphological
context and again this is a key
transition step because a lot of the
profiling technologies which i discussed
previously
gene expression profiling and proteomics
are essentially mash up technologies
where you take a piece of tumor tissue
and
combine it together mash it up together
and look at expression of proteins or
our genes but within the entire milieu
of the different cell types within that
tissue whereas within a tissue microwave
you can actually look at expression of
those markers within that cellular
context you can also look at dna
alterations we've actually published
some recent work looking at micro rna
alterations within tmas
so really the power of tma is really
it's a an opportunity to actually
transition from this discovery to
a higher degree of validation where you
can take
for example candidates which emerge from
a gene expression study classical
genetics
sorry i just had a bit of a problem
sorry i i just want to just check if
everybody can hear me okay sorry i just
had a bit of a problem and so anyway
i'll just push on here
so
in terms of
this idea of
one only area that's really a
revolutionized
pathology is the advent of digital
pathology where you can actually create
high resolution digital scans of these
traditional glass slides which are used
by pathologists and this facilitates two
activities one you don't have to share
glass slides around to your colleagues
you can actually share the information
online and this really greatly
facilitates manual assessment of this
data
another area that's very useful is that
you can actually start to use
computational tools to actually replace
some of the kind of i suppose
cumbersome approaches which are used for
for manual assessments so for example
you can actually quantify staining or
different different patterns within
tissue and i'm going to talk about that
later
now what i'm going to talk briefly now
is really about
the use of particular biomarkers in
breast cancer
and specifically this
graph our table shows the current fda
approved biomarkers in breast cancer and
you can see that really all all breast
cancers are assessed for three proteins
fundamentally at the start which would
be the estrogen receptor it's downstream
target the progesterone receptor and
her2 which is the opposite of drug
target for
her2 based therapies like herceptin
now there are some other markers which
people kind of use in a lesser manner
but rfda approved and again as i
mentioned that you have the mama
printasa which was approved back in
2007.
and again the question that these assays
really and particularly the
manufacturing architect x assay
ask is can the metastatic and
therapeutic potential be predicted by
whole tissue analysis of the primary
tumor
and what we're talking about really is
uh can we be clarifying that the
molecular can we predict an event that's
going to happen a number of years down
the line
i mentioned i'm going to talk just in a
bit more detail about this kind of
seminal study by laura fanfield and
lenny bernards back in nature in 2002
where they actually looked at um just
under 80 patients
where they actually split into two
different groups essentially a good
prognosis group which displayed
or sorry a poor prognosis group which is
displayed evidence of distant metastasis
within five years and then a good
prognosis group which didn't display
this phenotype and essentially carried a
gene expression profiling looking at
about 25 000 transcripts and they found
70 genes which could actually predict
this event in just over 80 of patients
and that really led to the genesis of
mammograms what's interesting is that
this particular
diagnostic assay which has been
commercialized by
agenda is being tested in a prospective
manner in a very large scale study
called mind act where they're going to
profile essentially 6000 early stage
node negative tumors and really
benchmark this new molecular diagnostic
versus standard criteria which are used
in europe called the saint gallin
criteria
and again if you
if for example the
traditional criteria and the new
molecular diagnostic agree that the
patient is low risk they're not they're
they're not given chemotherapy if they
agree that they're high risk they're
given chemotherapy and if they disagree
the patients are randomized and at the
end of the study which where we think
that the data will come out sometime
next year we'll actually know which
which assay or which which type of
strategy is the best in terms of
prediction
and again we have a similar type of
study ongoing a prospective study
called taylor x
which is being carried out worldwide
testing the utility of the oncotype dx
assay we're looking at 10 000 patients
now a number of years ago i had a
fortune of hosting a professor bob
milliken in my lab as a fulbright
scholar and bob unfortunately died in
october 2012
uh but he he and chuck prue really made
some key observations or kind of came up
with this concept that you could
actually potentially mimic
the molecular diversity that's seen in
breast cancer by using a small panel of
traditional and more novel immune
chemical markers and this may provide a
maybe a more low cost clinically
applicable too
and so this is indicated here so a chuck
producer sorely a number of years ago
actually came up with this concept that
you can actually
subdivide breast cancer in various
different
subgroups for example luminal a luminal
b
her2 positive
basal like or normal breast like based
on gene expression data and these
subgroups have prognostic impact in
terms of links for patient survival
but you can actually represent that
molecular diversity already subgroups by
using traditional markers like er pr and
her2 and some cytokeratins
and
so you can use a a lower cost tool to
actually
subdivide patients in this context
and so um doug ross
who
was a kind of key person in the gene
expression field a number of years ago
he set up this company called applied
genomics which is uh was taken over by
clarion a couple of years ago
and he actually did something that most
people don't do in a gene
expression-based experiment where
what he did is he actually took a
standard
large court of genes which
were outputs of a gene expression
experiment and actually got commercial
antibodies against these particular
targets
and then used so hundreds of antibodies
against these various different targets
and then screened those antibodies and
totally independent series of patient
samples and ask the question which of
those markers which were originally
identified at the rna level translated
at the protein level as being useful as
prognostic markers
and so dog actually came up with a panel
of five proteins including p53 and then
four more novel markers when combined
together could offer a prognostic impact
in terms of predicting patient outcome
within this particular subset of early
stage breast cancer patients er positive
and lymph node negative patients
and so we had a similar idea a number of
years ago actually got funding from the
eu for this particular program called
target breast and this involved
my home university as well as london
university in sweden
the netherlands cancer institute which
was where renee bernard is based as well
as a gender who was pushing forward
mammoprint and a telepathology company
called slidepad and the focus of this
particular program was really taking
only data and then trying to identify
candidate genes which were linked with
differential outcome of breast cancer
and then try to verify these at a
protein level
and so our strategy was really to
analyze dna migrate data come up with
candidates then get antibodies from a
particular resource which i caught talk
about in a minute called a protein atlas
project the specificity of these
antibodies using cell culture models
where we modify the protein of interest
then actually and once we're happy that
the antibody is specific we put onto a
tma
of large number of clinical specimens
and then correlate the staining with uh
we quantify the staining and then
correlate that expression information
with survival
so the particular tissue microwaves we
got work came from a source in sweden uh
particularly euron lamberg and karen
gerstrom
and the swedish are extremely good at
collecting
this type of clinical material but also
having long-term follow-up on patients
and so in some cases we have we have
follow-up data for up to 20 years
and these these types of materials also
come with a whole variety of other
clinical parameter information
and so uh again uh approximately it's
probably about seven eight years ago
following various different in-house
discovery approaches and other people's
papers we came up with a really hit list
of 250 genes that we thought could be
interesting in a breast cancer context
which tracked progression in some way
and when we looked for commercial
antibodies against these targets we were
pretty um unsuccessful and so we
submitted a list of these 250 targets to
a worldwide call by the human protein
atlas to generate antibodies and again i
would encourage people to if you're not
familiar with this to to look at this
particular website and so the human
protein atlas is really a fantastic
effort it's a not-for-profit group
based in sweden
where they're generating
antibodies against essentially all
proteins all non-redundant human
proteins and they've pretty much got i
think half the proteome covered at this
point
they can actually interrogate
information online
in respect to protein expression and get
access to these antibodies
and so what they do is they actually
express a pretty big chunk of the
protein then they they express a
large polypeptide from that protein
they generate um
affinity purified
polyclonal
antibodies derived from rabbit then
they're purified and then you go through
a whole range of different specificity
assessments which are screened on
protein raised or screened on a variety
of different normal and cancerous tissue
from humans various different cell lines
so you get a lot of data already
in your hands before you get access to
the antibody
the process is reasonably lengthy it
takes two years we submit a list of 250
genes to that to the program uh 100 rory
and other people's programs for antibody
production and 150 were put onto
the program specifically for early
access for our studies
in terms of success rates you get about
40 percent success rate coming through
the system and over the last number of
years we've been actually profiling the
expression of um are using these
antibodies profile expression of
particular proteins on tmas and it's
going to give you just a brief example
of the type of data we've generated
so one particular marker called pdz k1
we originally identified
as being correlated with a good outcome
in a gene expression based data set
sorry one second there's a q a up here
okay sorry i'll go back so there was a
um
we had originally identified as being
correlated with
good outcome based on gene
expression-based data an antibody was
created against be psak-1 by the protein
atlas and then screen and the totally
independent series of patient samples
now in this case you can see on this on
the
image that we create we really use a
traditional scoring approach where we a
categorical approach from zero one plus
two plus and three plus in terms of
staining what we see is that the
use of this
marker as a prognostic indicator or an
indicator of good outcome also uh works
at a protein level
and so we've just published a paper in
bmc cancer where what we've described is
a three marker panel
which is comprised of this psak-1
protein which is an indicator of good
prognosis as well as two markers of poor
prognosis analyn
and pbk
and really if you combine what i'm
showing here is really the the each of
those markers on a singular level where
you have on the top panel you have the
gene expression based information for
analyn pbk and pdzk1
where you can see low analyte correlates
with better outcome higher analym
correlates with poor outcome the same is
true for pbk and you get an inverted
scenario for pdz k1 because the
correlates were good prognosis
on the bottom panel what you're seeing
is
the value of those proteins as
prognostic indicators using these newly
derived antibodies and a totally
independent series of patient samples
and again they're they hold their value
and again really what we're trying to do
here is really combine these markers
together because we want to develop
something maybe an equivalent an
alternative to oncotype dx or memory
print that is maybe simpler and maybe
more effective and so what we currently
have is a novel threeplex assay on the
left-hand side you can see the
combination of these markers at the rna
level they're reasonably effective which
at the protein level they're very
strikingly effective where if you've got
high pd's at k1 low pbk and low analyn
it's a very good prognostic indicator
where you've got the open scenario it's
a it's a poor prognostic indicator
and again
the power of this
previous system which i talked about
called breastmark where you have all of
this gene expression data integrated we
can actually go back now and look at the
expression of those three markers in
that
data set
and so if you ask the question
across those four and a half thousand uh
patient samples and many of those
contained information on gene expression
information on those three markers we've
essentially got ten data sets just over
one half thousand patients where we have
that type of data what's interesting
even across these different ten data
sets and different technology platforms
these uh collection of three markers
hold utility uh as a
as a signature
so what i'm really gonna shift now is
really the use of automated image
analysis
so if you look at conventional manual
assessment of
ihd data it's fraught with problems
we there's lots of studies showing the
subjectivity of manual quantitation it's
very time consuming there's a lot of
variability in terms of uh data well
really the pathologist really is the
kind of gold standard that a lot of even
currently used therapeutics like
herceptin uh tamoxifen a lot of these
drugs which are used on day-to-day with
uh within the cancer context you read
the gatekeeper as a pathologist in terms
of the quantitation
with automated image analysis it's
really a new tool that the pathologists
can use which can actually try to
fast-track their process where you can
really provide objective quantitation of
iot data you can get reproducible data
but importantly you can also get
continuous output data
and so about five years ago we reviewed
this whole area of automated image
analysis in a histopathological context
and it's really a massive growth area
i'm not going to focus on all of the
different aspects today i'm particularly
focused on quantitation of bright field
images conventional
staining of um via immune chemistry
there are a whole range of different
areas of interest for example the
development of multi multiplex
fluorescence based assays like like aqua
and so the mainstream application is
really can we develop automated
solutions to actually quantify
staining of particular proteins for
example it could be a nuclear protein
like your or a membrane protein like
her2
in an automated manner
and so
ph a former phd student in my lab elton
rexopage he developed an intuitive
self-learning system
which we've subsequently commercialized
into a technology called ic mark
and what we're showing here just an
example of this
so if you look at looking on this image
you see a conventional stain for the
eastern receptor where you get on the
left hand side you've got um
essentially a conventional staining
where you can see the brown brown dots
are essentially cancer cells nuclei
cancer cells which are positive for that
marker what's quite challenging is to
find the cancer cells in the background
stroma within the background stroma
which are negative for eor
and so what elton did is he actually
developed a system which actually
learned the morphological features of
those tumor cells based on the actual
cells which are possible for that marker
such that you could actually find the
tumor cells within that background
stroma which are negative for that
marker of interest and you can see that
on the right hand side
the the cells which are indicated in
blue are the tumor cells which are
negative for er where the cells in red
are actually positive for er now what's
the value of this well the value is is
in terms of a clinical decision so we
tested the utility of this particular
approach in over a thousand breast
cancer patients across three different
clinical cohorts
and what we're showing here is really
just a comparison and between the
automated data on the y-axis and the
manual assessment data and in this case
we're using a kind of binary cutoff of
if you're greater than 10 positive
you're considered you are positive if
you're less than 10 positive you're
considered er negative what you can see
here is a pretty good correlation
between the manual data and the
automated data but obviously with the
automated data you get a spread of uh
results
across three different chords we see the
same thing with the
other widely used marker progesterone
receptor which is kind of a downstream
indicator or a effector gene of eor
and so what we're really uh interested
in this particular uh
schematic
i'm just looking at one particular
clinical chord so i'll just go back just
a couple of slides because it just
describes it here
so one of the courts that we used was
from a randomized control to maximum
trial where half the patients
approximately received no treatment
whatsoever no systemic therapy the other
half receives tamoxifen
and the benefit of this for two years
the benefit of this is you can actually
try to pull out the patients which are
er positive based on image analysis data
and then ask the question does tamoxifen
have a treatment related effect
um you can do that also for pr and and
in this case you can see that there is a
divergence in terms of survival and this
really shows that you can actually use
image analysis uh two rules to quantify
a marker that has created a predictive
ability
and so what we did is we actually um
packaged up this approach we actually
secured
we've recently secured a us patent and
we've eu patent pending on this approach
and really over the last number of years
we've set about validating this approach
across
multiple cancer types and also expanding
out its utility so we now have a
particular tool called iet mark
which is a novel a proprietary approach
where we can actually quantify immense
chemical staining we can look at nuclear
stains cytoplasmic stains and membrane
stains
as again as i mentioned we've spent the
last number of years publishing a
variety of different papers
showing the utility of this particular
approach across multiple cancer types
we can also do interesting things where
we can actually use
image analysis data this continuous data
that's derived from this approach linked
with survival information to actually
objectively define new cutoffs and
patient subgroups we've looked at what
classical markers and novel markers but
also we've looked at not only
quantifying tumor
cell markers but also looking at immune
cell infiltrate and other applications
so remember this particular signature
that we identified previously that based
on manual data worked pretty effectively
we've been actually able to automate
this assay now we get good correlation
between the automated data and the
manual scores for this particular
signature
our probably most powerful data to date
is from a prostate study where
our collaborator anders bartel from lund
he'd previously worked published a study
on this particular protein called msmb
and he had used manual assessment on
about 500 patients and shown that an
inverse association with biochemical
recurrence and then he had gotten access
to essentially another two and a half
thousand patient samples and really
really needed a
faster way of analyzing this huge
resource of clinical specimens
and so the first thing we did is we
actually compared
our
automated data versus this
manual data on the set of 500 patients
and then looked at the entire cohort
so what we're looking at here is just
kind of a representative image of
a low expressing sample and a high
expressing sample for this particular
marker
what you can see here is a kaplan-mars
survival plot where we have all
essentially 3000 patients within this
study and we can actually show that
using this image analysis acquired data
you can actually show that this protein
holds predictive value or in terms of
prognostic value
and again and this is another study
that was mentioned that was published
with lisa cousins in cancer discovery
the first issue
and what we're doing something pretty
simple here
there's a big interest now in the cancer
field to look at immune cell
infiltration and looking at correlations
with outcome
what we're simply doing here is using
different uh markers for different
inflammatory cells so cd4 positive cells
cb 8 positive cells or looking at
macrophage content and essentially using
the power of this image analysis tool to
look at
density of these immune cells within the
entire tumor area and then correlating
these density measurements with survival
and depending on the type of immune cell
that you have or inflammatory cell and
macrophage this has differential
prognostic impact and you can actually
combine that as a signature in itself
so i'll just briefly mention uncle mark
again i just wanted to indicate that i i
also had a commercial interest so i spun
out this company a number of years ago
really with the idea that we want to
transition some of our discoveries
particularly using this digital
pathology based approach
and so currently uncle mark is still
heavily invested in r d we're working
across a number of different cancer
types we're working breast cancer
prostate and colorectal cancer
specifically and we're working um
particularly armed with funding from the
eu we have received four and a half
million euro in eu funding really
covering these different
cancer areas
so what i want to do is also talk about
a new initiative
which kind of i recently kind of
taken over it's called breast predict
and this is a
very large research program it's a
program
essentially encompassing
pretty much all the breast cancer
researchers are highly active breast
cancer researchers within ireland
and it's the first of a very large scale
kind of nationwide initiative of breast
cancer
and so we know that for example breast
cancer is not just one disease we know
that there's a huge amount of diversity
between patients
even if you look at different tumors
from different patients you've got again
variations in terms of
molecular characteristics and again we
have this phenomenon with of within
tumor heterogeneity at a molecular level
and so we've had a lot of advances in
biology and huge information in the
molecular level but we really need now
to transition from this is really take
this new data to redefine how we treat
breast cancer really with the ultimate
goal of precision therapy
we also now need to take on board what's
coming out from systems biology in terms
of pathway network modeling and build
that into the system identify putative
nodes which are kind of driving cancer
in a particular way
we need to use this type of data
to actually better understand how tumors
respond or resist treatment
we also need to get better at actually
sampling patients during their course of
treatment particularly
sampling patients longitudinally
throughout their treatment
course
and so this breast predict program which
actually started in october of this
year's it's a five-year research program
and
a very large scale program we're
actually bringing together three
different components we're bringing
together uh
translational researchers which are
coming up with discoveries for example
using molecular profiling with medical
oncologists also taking a
population-based perspective of cancer
cliffy breast cancer
and our aspiration is really to combine
molecular data clinical data but also
population-based information within a
fully unified nationwide database
and then use this information to
actually inform
what are the most appropriate diagnostic
diagnostics and therapies to use within
our patient population
again this is a figure which recently
came out on a recently published gap
analysis in the breast cancer research
within the journal breast cancer
research
sponsored by the breast cancer campaign
what we're indicating here is really the
i suppose a treatment course of an
individual
or series of individuals with breast
cancer
and really what you'd like to do rather
than just sampling the primary tumor you
want to be able to get in there and
actually sample
like or obtain biological materials from
patients throughout their entire
treatment course and particularly one
area that's difficult is sampling of
metastases relapse disease and so we
have within the program a particular
focus on actually getting access to this
disseminated material and then comparing
the primary and the corresponding
methods from individuals
kind of questions we're asking within
this program are
so the kind of problems we're asking
uh within this um large-scale program
is really
questions around uh for example we know
that
patients who take aspirin pre-diagnosis
to breast cancer seem to have a
differential outcome
based on population-based information
what we want to do is really verify this
but also probe this at a mechanistic
level
we're interested in actually um
tracking how tumor tumors change during
or evolve over time during treatment
looking at molecular diversity during
treatment but also one aspect that we're
focusing on is really there's lots of
new and exciting drugs out there in the
in the cancer field particularly the
breast cancer field but we're not really
sure how to effectively combine these
together can we come up with a more
rational basis for combination and again
taking on board computational biology
and systems medicine approaches
another program which i'm involved with
which
kind of refers to this digital pathology
area is called fastpan
and this is a program which is
specifically focused on prostate cancer
and this involves essentially two
different aspects we're interested in
looking at morphological subgroups
within prostate cancer people might be
familiar with gleason grading which is
kind of current used approach which is
trying to subdivide prostate cancer into
different
categories and then correlating that
with
how you treat the patient we're trying
to maybe get around that by using more
novel and sophisticated approaches for
looking at diversity
in terms of morphological subgroups
we're also interested in looking at
again this image analysis based solution
to quantify prognostic biomarkers
what's unique about this program is that
we're actually also bringing in a new
element which is high performance
computing because
image analysis is all well and good but
without high performance computing
there's uh there's a potential kind of
delay effect
so this is a collaboration with
groups in northern ireland with queens
university belfast and also a spin out
from there called path excel
so one last uh eu program which i'm
going to briefly mention is called
rather
and this is a program i coordinate it's
about midway in the program
it's quite an exciting program what
we're doing is we're focusing on two
particular subsets of breast cancer
which are
particularly challenging to treat
so there's a group of
approximately 15 of breast cancers which
are called triple negative where they
don't explain expression of the estrogen
receptor pr
or her2 and therefore aren't really
kind of hot candidates for targeted
therapy
there's also another subgroup there's
about 10 of
breast cancer patients which
are what are called invasive lobular
carcinomas and this is a pretty much
understood understudied soap group of
patients
and these patients generally display a
poor response to systemic chemotherapy
and so in this particular program we're
actually focused at looking at kinome
alterations within 150 triple negative
breast cancers and 150 invasive lobular
carcinomas as well as a series of
representative cell lines from those
different subgroups and we're doing a
kind of multi-ohmic approach
where we're looking at uh mutational
profiling using kaino capture based uh
systems this is work that's been done in
renee bernard's lab in the nki
we're looking at kinase activation using
reverse phase protein arrays this is
taking place in the institute curie is
in within cherry du bois lab
we're also using a copy number analysis
using whole genome
snip arrays
to look at whole genome copy number
variation but also specifically zooming
in on the kind of alterations this work
is taking place in carlos carlos's lab
in cambridge and then finally we're also
taking a kind of an rna-based
perspective using both gene expression
arrays and rna sequencing and this work
has been done in agenda and also in my
home institution ucd
what's interesting with this program
we've actually completed the actual
discovery part where we've actually
obtained uh ohmic data from these
different platforms across um for all of
those specimens and really now we're in
the final stages of integrating this
information and we hope to get a really
kind of landmark paper initially which
really redefines uh
these particular subgroups of
of breast cancer particularly invasive
globular breast cancer at a molecular
level
the next stage of the program is really
take those the discoveries now and start
to use it practically is there some
novel kinase alterations that we can
find which are enriched or altered in
those particular subgroups of
breast cancer that can be used to inform
downstream and stratified medicine
trials we have funding ring fence within
the program for
companion diagnostic trials to actually
test that concept
one
we have an analogous program within the
colorectal cancer space where we're
looking at a series of it's called uh up
at the side
and we're actually looking at a variety
of different markers within the
apoptosis signaling pathway and
applying a systems medicine approach to
quantify
the or to to model this particular
pathway but using information derived
from ihc staining of colorectal cancer
specimens
to predict chemotherapy response
so what i'd like to do is just finish
off by indicating the various different
funding sources which have supported
this work particularly the irish cancer
society
enterprise ireland the health research
board of ireland science foundation
ireland and the european commission
also what i'd like to do is thank the
various different people which have
contributed to this work
particularly
national collaborators and international
collaborators from sweden
uk and the us and also people on within
my lab both current members and former
members of my group
so i'm happy to take some questions on
my actually sorry i i actually was
supposed to
also indicate that people can obtain
continuing education credits they can
actually go to this particular resource
so what i'll do is i might click up the
q a box and maybe go through some of the
questions that people may have
i've just got one question so
if people have other questions please
please feel free to to ask that
so there's a question which is
um here can antibody
generated be used in immunotherapy
so what's in the particular focus of our
study to uh in the area of immunotherapy
we
were really interested in use of
antibodies from the point of view of
just conventional antigen
detection
and so
we didn't go out there with the mission
to develop antibodies for therapeutic
purposes
so again i'm happy to take any other
questions if people are interested
okay i'm still waiting for questions
so
that says question here have you worked
with optimers to
no so we we're i'm familiar with optimus
but we uh we i i we haven't actually
specifically worked with optomers
obviously optimus can be
particularly useful for from a
therapeutic context also
so again if people have any other
questions i'm i'm happy to take them
okay i might yeah i might wrap it up
actually so if i don't if i don't get
another question in the next minute i'm
going to wrap it up so
um thanks very much for everybody who
has listened to me i really appreciate
that
and uh i think we got about between 70
to 80
attendees okay there's a question here
okay
is there a specific biomarker for brain
cancer which can be detected using
antibodies
to be honest i don't know i'm sure there
are lots of
candidate biomarkers which are kind of
being postulated being useful
for for brain cancer it depends what
kind of application is it something that
you're looking for something that is
exclusively expressed in brain cancerous
tissue
or are you looking at specific markers
that can be used for predicting outcome
so i certainly would suggest you look up
the um protein atlas resource and then
you can you can actually potentially
screen for markers i'm pretty sure that
they have uh
brain cancer material there which are
represented on their resources
so i'm gonna wrap up now so thanks very
much
don do you want to close down there